[Música]
[Aplausos]
desde donde están quisiera preguntarles
quienes de ustedes que consideran
creativos
ahora quiero que piense en el por qué
porque se consideran creativos o por qué
no
quiero que piensen en alguna rutina que
tengamos desde que nos despertamos al ir
al cole al ir a la u
al llegar al trabajo o lo que solemos
hacer los fines de semana
ocurre un imprevisto
para cartulina
y tenemos que maniobrar para volver a
acomodarnos a nuestra rutina
acaso no creen ustedes que el simple
manejo de nuestro tiempo es por su
naturaleza un proceso creativo yo creo
que así
usualmente no creemos en nuestro
potencial creativo le restamos
importancia a todo aquello que se nos
ocurre y por ende pensamos ahí y eso
para que si ya todo está inventado y si
no está inventado
am
pero ya hay que más se le ocurrirá
es precisamente esa barrera mental lo
que nos impide a las personas innovar
cambiar nuestros pensamientos y
actitudes para alcanzar la autenticidad
o como se dice entre vex tener ideas que
vale la pena difundir
y bueno como logramos esos de ser
creativos spoiler de todos nacemos
siendo creativos
pero qué es eso que se nos dice de la
creatividad distintas fuentes apuntan
que la creatividad también conocida como
inventiva humana surge a partir de una
fuerte base de conocimiento y
experiencia lo cual es una definición
que me genera conflicto
ya que en el caso de los niños podemos
ver que son creativos y ellos no cuentan
con el conocimiento y experiencia
necesarios para considerarse creativos
según esta definición cuando yo iba al
kinder me entregaban una hoja en blanco
y me pedían dibujar un león y bueno yo
para ese entonces no reconocía entre un
perro gato gallina pato caparazón un
dinosaurio bueno un dinosaurio si lo
hacía pero
am
yo plasmaba mi idea en el papel y yo no
tenía miedo yo era creativo
una vez a una niña le preguntaron sobre
el dibujo que estaba haciendo a lo que
ella contestó estoy dibujando adiós
suave como así nadie ha visto a dios y
por ende no sabemos cómo se ve
en cuatro minutos
tendrás la respuesta
esto es la creatividad
tal vez la niña por su experiencia con
dios puede ilustrarlo pero ella no
necesita el conocimiento que en este
caso lo que se nos ha hecho saber es que
como no sabemos cómo se ve dios no
podemos ilustrarlo
una vez que adquirimos conocimiento
perdemos creatividad ese es el principal
problema pero que se necesita para que
eso cambie
todo empieza desde la educación
esto es un poco
robinson uno de los pensadores sobre
educación y creatividad más importantes
del último siglo y es que yo no podría
estar más de acuerdo con lo que él
propuso la creatividad no es sólo que
sea tan importante como la educación
sino que debe ser parte integral de esta
y porque pues es simple sabían ustedes
que el modelo educativo actual se
remonta a la revolución industrial bueno
hace ya varios años
los métodos de enseñanza tradicional no
han cambiado en décadas lo que está
generando rezagos en nosotros los
estudiantes la mayoría
sentimos que el conocimiento adquirido
nos limita a lo que dice el libro a
replicar una y otra vez aquello que se
nos enseña y no se nos incita a ir más
allá a explorar cuestionarnos a
experimentar
la pandemia trajo consigo algunas
oportunidades acelerando la
transformación digital pero siento que
no se puede decir lo mismo en el ámbito
de la educación y en cuanto al
desarrollo de los jóvenes
para nosotros la pandemia significa un
stop en cuanto a nuestro
desenvolvimiento
nuestro principal enfoque era más qué
y aprender sobre lo poquísimo que nos
estaban enseñando cumplir con las
asignaciones lo cual se tornaba tedioso
y agotador
el año pasado fui invitado a formar
parte de una organización de estudiantes
dentro del colegio al que asisto llamado
sedes don bosco y esto fue
algo que cambió mi forma de pensar sin
una sola explicación accedí a formar
parte
bueno aquí dentro con ayuda de mi
mentora
todas las personas que formamos parte
pudimos reconocer el potencial creativo
que todos llevamos dentro
y eso se convirtió en una motivación
para mí
el ser capaz de trabajar mis ideas en un
tiempo lleno de incertidumbre me hizo
notar varias diferencias en cuanto a mi
actitud y en la actitud de las personas
que formamos parte pero analizaba a mis
compañeros de clase y no tenían esa
misma ilusión esa chispa de poder hacer
algo nuevo a partir de todo esto con
ayuda de mi mentor a tamara sancho
fallas y un grupo increíble de
estudiantes estableció una propuesta que
está orientada a que la creatividad
pueda florecer a partir de la
interacción entre los jóvenes un espacio
en donde los mismos pueden recibir el
apoyo de su institución educativa para
generar ideas que beneficien a su
comunidad estudiantil
este proyecto fue presentado en el
encuentro nacional de líderes del
ministerio de educación pública del
presente año y obtuvo el primer lugar
más que explicarles que era el proyecto
quiero compartirles el porque una vez
que finalizamos la educación media cada
uno de nosotros empieza a actuar en
consecuencia nuestra vocación y
encontrarla no es una tarea sencilla
peor aún cuando vemos que el sistema
educativo no nos brinda herramientas
para que esa vocación esté alineada a un
verdadero propósito
si la inventiva humana o creatividad
fuera parte esencial del proceso de
enseñanza aumentaría el interés de los
estudiantes por generar nuevas ideas
todos tenemos niveles de conocimiento y
experiencia distintos y por ende no
todos vamos a desarrollar una misma idea
pero nuestra intención siempre será
alcanzarla y que esté eso que responde a
la necesidad de alcanzar un ideal la
vocación
en cuanto a la creatividad la sociedad
misma es la que construye este concepto
tan complejo en donde cuando se nos
habla de la creatividad pensamos en
picasso mozart y shakespeare
y bueno que tenían estas tres personas
en común un trauma pero ese no es el
punto
estas tres personas están relacionadas
al mundo del arte
acaso sólo pensamos en el arte cuando se
habla de la creatividad la creatividad
no es exclusiva al arte como muchos
creen ni a la ciencia ni a la tecnología
la creatividad es un estilo de vida y
por ende se aplica a todos los ámbitos
de la misma
creo que una meta como sociedad debe ser
que la educación el conocimiento no
restrinjan la creatividad de los jóvenes
sino que land art scan claro está que
para esto debemos cambiar nuestra forma
de pensar y la educación es clave más
que una obligación didáctica debemos
comprender que toda fuente de educación
tiene una obligación creativa
la creatividad se esconde en todo lo que
hacemos solo hace falta una vocación que
nos ayuda a encontrarla
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]